you
not so very long ago though the city of
New York Astoria from the land beside
Central Park a new sort of building
sprung a montage of modern conveniences
the residential high-rise building group
running hot water
elevators doormen all of it was new but
it's been a long time that we've been
placing ourselves in dwellings close to
the sky and asking ourselves the
perennial question who gets the top
floor and why were these vertical
experiments reserved for elites or to
warehouse the poor away from the streets
like all good stories the high-rise has
its own creation myth the bible's Tower
of Babel and gods reaction forth with
people of one language high into the
clouds the tower they built but God
disapproved so people broken into many
languages across the earth he spilt
the Romans were the first to build early
apartment living multi-story blocks
called in July but made mud and timber
they were unforgiving the higher the
floor the cheaper the rent the working
poor lived here fires and collapses they
couldn't prevent
in the glyphs of Arizona mysterious
forms of housing soon appeared it's been
supposed these cliff dwellings are from
where the elites commandeer
in rural China's Fujian province in
stacked circular homes of would hold
clans of families up to 80 live together
for the common good all rooms were equal
even windows doors and walls for
centuries communal living was part of
these people's laws
and another vertical wonder in Yemen's
dusty sands a medieval Manhattan of the
desert still occupied today made of mud
by the inhabitants own hands vertical
living got a major game changer when
Louis the 15th commissioned an early
elevator to his apartment in Versailles
from his mistress one floor above him
the King was known to hoist her down on
a chair so she could love him but
without reliable brakes test wage the
common man's dread they feared a
contraption that went up and down to
take off somebody's head and as the
elevator propelled the Industrial
Revolution people had to live near work
and it's industrial pollution in Berlin
London New York and others immigrants
crammed in with no sunlight to be with
their brothers for decades these
dwellers lived dive there without much
public sentiment cities were growing
with this notorious new walk-up called
the tenements
by the end of the century Manhattan's
Lower East Side was the world's densest
area by far and wide nobody cared until
a photographer reviewed the situation
Jacob Reese's stunning collection would
begin the conversation in 1901 major
housing reforms were read but much much
bigger changes were ahead the stuff of
which cities are now made whether
luxurious or forlorn the high-rises we
know it was now being born
you